معي وزير الخارجية العراقي
لمناقشة كل هذه
التطورات وسنبدأ أه
بالضربات الإيرانية على كل من العراق وسوريا
إيران تقول إنها نفذت
ضربات دقيقة ومستهدفة على ما تقول
إنها مقرات إرهابية في إدلب
سوريا ومركز تابع للموساد في
كل العراق لقد قمتم باستدعاء
الشئون الايرانية في بغداد للاحتجاج
على الهجمات وقد
كانت هناك امريكا وفرنسا وغيرها
مراكز تابعة للموساد تعمل
بالطبع لا هم امس هاجموا
اربيل واعتدوا على المدنيين  مناطق
داخل أربيل وأه يهاجمون
منزلاً به ويقتلون أعتقد أن
أربعة أشخاص وستة أشخاص قد
أصيبوا وجميعهم أكراد عراقيون
يأتي هذا على تلة الهجوم الأمريكي الأخير
بطائرة بدون طيار في بغداد كيف يمكن للعراق أن
يضمن ذلك'  تصبح المرحلة
فيما هو تصعيد تشعر
بتصاعد الصراع الإقليمي هنا من
المؤسف التوتر بين
واشنطن وتنوم
عادة عندما يكون هناك توتر بين
هذين البلدين أه العراقيون
يدفعون الثمن والقتال يدور
على الأراضي العراقية  والآن التوتر
بين الإسرائيليين والإيرانيين أيضا هو
نفسه ولهذا السبب الإيرانيون
لا يريدون أو لا يستطيعون مهاجمة
إسرائيل أه ثم يبحثون عن
أه للضحايا من حولهم لذلك
يهاجمون AR ماذا يمكن للعراق أن يفعل في هذا  في
هذه المرحلة ما هو ردكم في
المقام الأول، نحن ندين نحن ندين
هذه الهجمات ونعتبرها
عدوانًا وانتهاكًا
للقانون الدولي للقانون الدولي لذلك
اتخذنا إجراءات مختلفة وسنذهب
أيضًا إلى مجلس الأمن في
نيويورك ماذا  هل تعتقد أن مجلس الأمن الدولي
سيحقق أعتقد أه
سيكون هناك دعم كبير للموقف العراقي
ضد إيران إيران في الواقع
معزولة عن العالم كله لذا إذا
ذهب العراق إلى مجلس الأمن
وتم اعتبار العراق حليفاً لـ
إيران أه إذن ستخلق مشكلة كبيرة
في الداخل، لقد تحدثت عن
التوتر المتصاعد بين الولايات المتحدة وإيران
وأنت تحدد غزة
كجزء من ذلك، كما كنا ننقل التقارير
عن الهجمات في البحر الأحمر والولايات المتحدة
لو  رد التحالف على ذلك
بالتأكيد هناك شعور أه في منطقة الخليج والشرق
الأوسط شعور حقيقي
بالإحباط والقلق بشأن
موقف إدارة بايدن مما
يجري من كثيرين يقولون جيدا أننا نعلم أنه
كانت لدينا دعوات ل  وقف إطلاق النار في غزة،
العديد من الذين قالوا ما هي
خطة إدارة بايدن طويلة المدى لكل من
غزة وبالتأكيد للمنطقة الأوسع
للتأكد حقًا من أننا لا نرى هذا
التصعيد الأوسع، هل تشارك هذه
المخاوف والإحباطات الإقليمية اسمحوا
لي أولاً أه أن أذكر  أه الوضع في
غزة أه الحرب على أهل
غزة خلقت مشكلة كبيرة ليس
فقط للشعب الفلسطيني بل
للمنطقة بأكملها لذلك يجب وقف الحرب
وزيادة وفتح الباب
لمزيد من المساعدات الإنسانية لغزة التي سوف
ساعد في وقف الحرب في غزة
وممارسة المزيد من الضغط على
حكومة نتنياهو أه أه ستكون
الخطوة الأولى للوصول إلى وضع أقل
توتر أه في المنطقة أه لكن بالنسبة
لسياسة الولايات المتحدة أفهم
ذلك الآن أه العملية برمتها  لقد
بدأت الانتخابات في الواقع وأه هذا الأمر
متروك لحكومة الولايات المتحدة بشأن
نوع السياسة التي يقومون بتطويرها